joe rogan one of the seriously one of
the thought leaders in our country
i'm not saying that ironically he he is
i don't know if what it says about our
country but he is
he pointed out the other day he said you
know i wanted to send a video around
that i saw uh of
questioning the narrative on the
coronavirus and the lockdowns and the
treatment
but i couldn't send it even through a
private message you know i tried to send
a friend of mine a video the other day
on twitter
through a direct message and it was
blocked really
i couldn't send a direct message it's it
was
i was asking him if this was accurate
and it was a doctor who's talked about
ivermectin an ivermectin which is a
um it's a treatment for covet and this
doctor was saying that ivermectin is 99
effective in treating covit but that you
don't hear about it
because you can't fund vaccines when
there's an effective treatment
and this is i don't know if this guy's
right or wrong so i'm asking questions
so i go hey tell me about this so i send
it
it message not sent i try to send it
again message not sent i'm like oh my
god what's your email
i had to send it through email gotta
send it through email now i don't know
anything about ivermectin i don't even
really care that much that's not that's
not what interests me in this clip what
interests me in this clip is
joe rogan a famous powerful rich guy
couldn't send a private message just
asking
a scientific question couldn't engage in
science
couldn't try to follow the science
because the country the culture is being
run by a cartel
it's being run by these mobsters this
little corporate oligarchy in silicon
valley that's working with the
establishment all over the place
that is very different than our
constitutional system
purports to be on paper are we gonna
are we gonna assert our political right
and begin to exercise self-government
again are we just going to say ah man
whatever
move into the frail old age of our
republic and say whatever man it is what
it is
the choice is ours hey hold on a second
first i've just got to celebrate that we
haven't been taken off youtube
i thought i was sure that that show was
gonna i didn't think they were gonna
like that one but
if you're hearing this and seeing this
then the show is not off youtube yet
ring the bell like subscribe that is how
you will at least have a better chance
of getting notifications when we get
more videos out
i'll see you next time